[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
في فجر يوم الخميس اي في تمامه ساعه 12 و
48 دقيقه تصل الشمس الى اقصى ميل لها
ناحيه الجنوب اي انها تتعامد على مدار
الجديد ايش يعني هذا يعني بدايه البرد
الفعلي واطول ليله في السنه فالبرد الفعلي
لا يبدا الا اذا انحرفت الشمس من الجهه
الجنوبيه الى الجهه الشماليه والعامه
يقولون لا برد الا بعد الانصراف اي لا
ياتين البرد الشديد والذي يدخل مع الانسان
في فراشه ويخرج البخار من الجوف الا بعد
ما تنصرف الشمس من الجهه الجنوبيه الى
الجهه الشماليه وهذا اليوم هو اطول ليله
في السنه وبما ان الشمس بعيده عنا بمسافه
158 كيلو متر تقريبا فان هذا اليوم سيتخر
الى بعد سبعه ايام تقريبا وبالمجمل هذه
الايام سنعيش فيها اطول ليالي واقصر نهر
في السنه تطاول بيسو هذا الليل حتى رست
عينايا في بحر السهادي وباتت تمطر
العبارات عيني وعين الدمع تنبع من
وعادي
[تصفيق]
والشمس عندهم انقلابين وعبورين فان انقلبت
في حركتها من الجنوب الى شمال 21 ديسمبر
نعيش اطول ليالي السنه واذا انقلبت في
حركتها من الشمال الى الجنوب في 21 يونيو
نعيش اطول ليالي السنه وفي العبورين 11
مارس 27 سبتمبر يتساوى في طول الليل مع
النهار
يقلب الله الليل والنهار ان في ذلك لعبره
لاولي الابصار
[موسيقى]